sí
[Música]
cuando me invitaron a dar esta plática
memoria de la emoción además de un
privilegio me encanta
no contaba con los retos a los que me
enfrentaría con el paso de las semanas
nadie contaba con esto y la realidad
superó a la ficción
pasaban los esquizofrénicos días yendo
de la esperanza al enfado del miedo a la
frustración y obviamente sin poder
aterrizar ningún tema que me parecía
inspirador en medio de una avalancha de
emociones
nuestra agencia la panadería el fruto de
más de 20 años de trabajos y también un
sueño está en riesgo y mi vecino y el
restaurante la esquina y la competencia
y las aerolíneas los hoteles los
jugueteros italianos o chinos ahí me di
cuenta que no soy especial y sobre todo
no puedo sentirme culpable de algo por
lo que no puedo hacer más para evitar
que me pase por encima esta catástrofe
entonces empecé a replantear mi propia
realidad los porqueros para que es
analizando todo desde una óptica nueva y
sin saber bien la bien hacia donde
llevamos el mundo se había volcado a
tomar conciencia quizás una conciencia
total no pero colectiva y de pronto me
encontré con una foto que hace 20 años
no veía una familia viendo una película
alrededor de una sola pantalla que tiene
de raro que la viene el instagram de una
amiga en cuarentena con sus tres hijos y
su marido eso para mí creo nostalgia
pero para sus hijos en una novedad
nuestra vida no volverá a ser la misma
nuestras necesidades cambiaron nuestras
prioridades también y las emociones
saltaron a flor de piel la incertidumbre
el miedo los mensajes que antes nos
conmovía hoy perdían valor campañas que
no tenían el mismo significado y de
pronto todas las marcas se volcaron
sobre la nostalgia los mexicanos que
siempre estamos afuera somos felices
gritamos imagínate cuando vuelvas a
estar afuera y no es casual había que
conectar con las emociones
pero con qué emociones campañas pro
sociales ático vive todos los días se
estrenaban en cada medio la mayoría con
mensajes de autorreconocimiento y yo me
entendía es como si todos hubieran
puesto de acuerdo para recordarnos
cuántos años llevaban con nosotros si
eran 20 50 me estaban acompañando sí
pero que mandaba mensajes de empatía
explicándome como esta tragedia mundial
ataque a todos y sin importar su
demografía edad socioeconómico nada
por qué no aprovechar este tiempo para
estar en familia reflexionar leer ese
libro que no hemos leído en tantos años
o cocinar y si no los culpo pero de qué
me servía mí en mi vaivén de la recámara
el comedor a la sala la cocina sin poder
encontrar una respuesta a que iba a ser
con la quincena si no podía cobrarle a
mis clientes que estaban haciendo
básicamente lo mismo que yo pero con
prioridades distintas
en una buena idea sin duda lo era
pero era un útil y leer ese libro para
lo que hoy me quitaba el sueño un poco
menos
2 me di cuenta como había una que otra
marca que se acercaba a mí y notaba como
esta conexión que yo no había notado
antes porque me decía lo que si
necesitaba visa sin importar si era mi
marca favorita uno me daba las
respuestas a mis necesidades o aquellas
necesidades de los que me importaban
invitándome a la acción ese banco que
fue el primero en decirme te voy a
desplazar tu deuda cuatro meses aunque
no fuera mi banco levanto mis eje media
también día afortunadamente todos los
bancos de oxígeno ya no importaba quién
había sido el primero eso era una
alternativa para mí
hoy gran parte de la población salvo su
flujo gracias a poder aplazar esos meses
de sus deudas con créditos personales o
tarjetas
hoy estamos inertes atentos a todo lo
que escuchamos a todo lo que vemos hoy
la vida está en pausa
hoy aquellos que me resuelven la vida
sin tener que salir de casa servicios
que quizá antes no valoraba se han
vuelto indispensables el crecimiento el
comercio electrónico lassad se envió hoy
son un salvavidas literalmente un
salvavidas y de pronto lo que no había
sucedido en años todos estábamos
conectados en unas cuantas semanas
mujeres de todas las edades
aprendiendo a vender en línea sus
productos de catálogo siendo un ejemplo
de resiliencia en todas sus comunidades
a diferencia de otros
esos mañana si podrán decirme te
acuerdas que estuve contigo durante el
cob y eso seguro lo voy a recordar
escuchemos al mercado no asumamos lo que
creemos
hoy estamos en una incertidumbre que no
termina viviendo en carne propia la
palabra cuarentena que se convierte en
sesentena que antes nunca habíamos
experimentado por lo menos no mi
generación hoy todo es distinto
hoy ese sentimiento este lo más profundo
de mi memoria celular de mis acciones de
mis emociones significan mucho más hoy
tengo miedo el miedo por definición es
ese sentimiento que surge al percibir
que algo muy valioso para mí está en
riesgo algo lo amenaza percepción que
quizás no sea realidad pero para mí lo
es
ahí están todas las cosas que me
importan aquello que me importa vincula
mis emociones y ahí tomo mis decisiones
pero no solo yo tú y todos nuestros
clientes
una marca que no conecta con las
emociones eso en un logotipo un ron un
dibujo un juego de colores con letras
una marca que sabe conectar con la
emoción en momentos de crisis se
convierte en un compañero evoca la
gratitud que básicamente significa que
alguien me ha dado ha protegido algo que
es valioso para mí y en la gran mayoría
de las circunstancias me sentiré
obligado a responder en cuanto tenga
oportunidad
las marcas no venden productos venden
emociones aquellas con las marcas que
conecto son las que me hablan las que me
identifican y yo las identificó a través
de la nostalgia la tristeza el orgullo
el miedo la alegría todas esas emociones
en un instante harán que el impulso de
compra se materialice o no
la emoción no actúa sola me hace actuar
o no actuar
como marca si quiero conectar con mi
audiencia tengo que identificar cuál es
la emoción que rige en cada momento de
su vida
sobre esa identificar la emoción y
después la oportunidad que se me da ahí
es en donde está ese vínculo
si se abrir esa puerta durante una
crisis no se cerrará jamás
las crisis no se deben aprovechar se
deben capitalizar a largo plazo en ambos
sentidos el beneficio mutuo es la clave
la reciprocidad es un impulso natural
del ser humano
ahí es donde radica esa respuesta
si entendemos de emoción con la que
debemos conectar es el principio de ahí
encontramos a que responde a esa emoción
que busca que necesita o que la
complementa y ahí podremos entonces
planear una estrategia para provocar una
respuesta a eso
no es tan complicado pero para conectar
con la emoción hay sólo una clave
debemos ser verdaderos debe ser
congruente los clientes no son tontos y
mucho menos en un estado de elevada
conciencia como están
si no logramos conectar se convierte en
un satisfactor inmediato no conecta si
yo regalo dinero seguramente comprar mi
producto pero realmente volverán si no
regalo dinero mañana quizá no
para que yo te crea tiene que estar en
segundo plano el beneficio de la marca
debe ser real si yo me pongo a regalar
cubrebocas en la entrada del método con
tu logo la idea no es mala pero conectar
a lo recordaré probablemente no es como
dar volantes que aunque digan algo
interesante quizá no lo lean pero qué
pasa si el repartidor de pan de caja del
tendero le regala un cubrebocas a esa
persona en la mano
se completa la cadena de valor de cuido
me importa que no te enfermes para que
yo también pueda cumplir con mi trabajo
claro mi producto se va a vender gracias
a que tú no te enfermes pero empecé por
ti
hoy el miedo no se va a ir hoy ya
conocemos esto mañana también lo tendré
solo que hoy es un poco más de amigo y
es un aliado que todas las marcas deben
tener porque les recordara qué es lo que
es valioso para cada quien este miedo
que nos hace estar alertas a lo que hace
la competencia lo identifiquemos o no o
queramos decirlo con todas sus letras es
miedo
tenemos que estar alertas miedo a las
causas de fuerza mayor que hoy conocemos
mejor que nunca y antes era sólo una
cláusula de un contrato que no tenía
validez nuestra vida se ha reseteado hoy
nos enfrentamos una nueva realidad
porque novela como una oportunidad de ir
más profundo a nuestro fondo a nuestros
productos a lo más profundo de nuestras
audiencias y reconectar con ellas ir a
los valores de la empresa y sobre eso
edificar una estrategia que realmente
construya sobre la marca
que se queme
y que no se quede solo porque estamos en
crisis
las emociones siempre están ahí no se
van y rigen nuestros actos
si logramos conectar la emoción con
nuestra razón de hacer las cosas no se
nos olvidará jamás
así como esta pandemia tampoco se
olvidará
entonces es o no una oportunidad
muchas gracias